T
BIDEN CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
>> FOR MORE ON THE CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, WE'RE
JOINED BY THE SENATOR FROM
TENNESSEE AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, MARSHA BLACKBURN,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME HERE.
IN 2018 I FOLLOWED A CARAVAN
FROM SAN PEDRO HONDURAS, 7,000
MILES TO THE U.S.
HE ENDED UP IN MEXICO, AND
CROSSED INTO EAGLE PASS.
AND WHAT WE MAY SEE NOW, IF
TITLE 42 GOES AWAY IS 10 TIMES
WHAT WE SAW FOUR YOOER
ERS
AGO AND WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS AND WHAT SHOULD BE DONE?
>> WHAT SHOULD BE DONE IS THAT
TITLE 42 SHOULD BE KEPT AND
GRIFF, AS YOU'RE MENTIONING AND
AS BRYAN MENTIONED IN HIS
REPORT, YOU LOOK HOW THE
NUMBERS HAVE ESCALATED UNDER
JOE BIDEN, WITH TITLE 42 IN
PLACE, AND THE EXPECTATION THAT
YOU WILL GO FROM 6,000 TO 7800
TO 18,000 PER DAY.
NOW, WHEN I HEARD THAT 18,000
FIGURE I LOOKED AT THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF TOWNS WE HAVE IN
TENNESSEE, WHICH IS 345.
OF THIS 345 TOWNS AND CITIES,
90% OF THEM ARE 18,000 OR FEWER
PEOPLE PER DAY.
SO, THIS WOULD BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF THE POPULATION OF
A TYPICAL TENNESSEE TOWN COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER EVERY SINGLE
DAY OF THE WEEK.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO DO THIS.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
DANGER TO THE SOVEREIGNTY AND
THE SECURITY OF OUR NATION AND
CRIME IN THE STREETS, DRUGS ON
THE STREETS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
GANGS, SEX TRAFFICKING, SOME OF
THOSE ARE THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS TALK
ABOUT THEY'RE HAVING TO
ADDRESS.
EVERY TOWN IS A BORDER TOWN.
EVERY STATE IS A BORDER STATE.
GRIFF: BUT SENATOR, OUTSIDE
OF--
>> YES, AND--
>> LEGAL COURT ACTION, WHAT CAN
REPUBLICANS IN THE MINORITY DO
TO TRY TO STOP THIS FROM
HAPPENING?
>> WE CAN LOOK AT THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS, AND MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THERE IS NO MONEY FOR
TITLE 42, FOR THE REMOVAL OF
TITLE 42.
WE ALSO CAN LOOK AT EXPANDING
TITLE 42 AND THERE IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR KEEPING
THAT, FORCING THAT ISSUE,
FORCING A FLOOR VOTE.
MAKING CERTAIN THAT TITLE 42
COVERS DRUGS AND GIVES EXTRA
ABILITY TO GO AFTER THESE DRUG
TRAFFICKERS.
I WAS DOWN IN BENTON COUNTY,
TENNESSEE YESTERDAY OVER IN THE
NORTHWEST PART OF THE STATE AND
OUR SHERIFF OVER THERE, SHERIFF
CHRISTOPHER, WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE PRESENCE OF FENTANYL AND
HOW PREVALENT THAT HAS BEEN.
THEY'VE SEEN SUCH AN UPTICK IN
THE PAST SIX MONTHS AND HE SAID
IF WE CAN'T SECURE THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER THAT WHEN THOSE
DRUG DEALERS COME ACROSS, IT'S
LIKE A SHOTGUN BLAST, YOU KNOW,
IT SPREADS EVERYWHERE.
GRIFF: AND IT IS INDEED.
AND JUST IN THE TIME WE HAVE
LEFT, I WANT TO ASK YOU ALSO
ABOUT ANOTHER STORY AND THAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S NEW
DISINFORMATION CZAR, NINA
JANKOWICZ.
YOUR THOUGHTS AND REACTIONS TO
THAT?
>> WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD
IS PUT THERE TO ALLOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO CENSOR
POLITICAL FREE SPEECH.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
TAKE AWAY YOUR FREE SPEECH AND
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO HAS SHOWN
THAT THEY ARE VERY PARTISAN,
THAT SHE IS GOING TO TAKE A
PARTISAN APPROACH.
WE KNOW THAT SHE BELIEVES
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS A REALLY
GREAT GUY AND SHE ALSO BELIEVES
THAT HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP IS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
BUT BY THE WAY, SHE WAS TO BE A
BROADWAY MUSICAL SINGING EXPERT
ON RUSSIA DISINFORMATION.
WE SEE WHAT THAT HAS GOTTEN US.
GRIFF: WELL, SHE'S CERTAINLY
CREATED